6 13 it is a tuesday morning well our
conquering the quarantine
series it's airing all week long here on
good day las vegas in the six o'clock
hour
we're looking at different ways to have
people uh have
they're looking at different ways people
rather have past the time over the past
year whether it's as we saw yesterday
nate making some spicy mayo or as we're
finding it today it's a little different
that's right and because of the pandemic
you know we've all spent a lot more time
stuck in our homes than ever before alex
yes we have and many people chose to
adopt or foster a pet during the
pandemic
it's great news for animals at local
shelters but it's also helped so many of
us
get through this tough year the walks
wags and smiles we needed them more than
ever this past year
and our pets were there as our homes
transformed into offices and classrooms
we got to spend more time with our fur
babies and as the pandemics continued
more
found their forever homes dora
baby girl rachel diehl fostered dora
from the animal foundation during the
holidays
we got her because we were gonna be home
alone for the holidays and thought it'd
be great to give a pup a place
to you know to stay and don't have to be
in the shelter after just a couple of
days
they knew dora would become part of the
family my boyfriend and i we were foster
fails
in 2020 over 8 000 animals were adopted
from the animal foundation alone
sometimes we get hundreds of phone calls
in the morning to our adoption hotline
as more people foster and adopt the
foundation is also getting fewer animals
into the shelter
a couple years ago you might have heard
stories about a dog that was here for
200 days 300 days we're just not really
seeing that right now which is a good
thing i think
the dog who's been here the longest
right now is maybe 12 days
which that's amazing our dogs have
gotten us outside and forced us
to be active you're doing it for
somebody else you're doing it for
you know another being and so it keeps
us kind of active
and happy say hi friends
they've protected the house provided
companionship
and some became more talented than we
ever will be
our pets have given us comfort and joy
in a year we needed it the most
i can't even tell you how much happiness
she brings she is
she's she's she's a reason to wake up in
the morning and smile
oh those dogs are so cute yeah so you
still do need to make an appointment to
see an animal at the animal foundation
and we've got that all on our website
for you but
yes we owe it to our pets i think for uh
entertaining us giving us a bit of humor
in this year absolutely should we give a
quick little pet shout out ourselves
this morning a little bit
oh there he is here's my bobo there's
beauty yes i am a bodhi's mom to us to
some
oh you got to sit at the table oh my
gosh
his trainer threw him a birthday party
for his first birthday
with other dogs they made him food and
everything so yeah
he's had a nice life oh there's our
christmas card where our cat
mink was saying i really don't want to
be part of this and here she is
receiving
new instructions from her home planet
oh she's such a beauty nade thank you
she adopted us
oh there's petey yeah he's uh he was
laying on my lap
petey became pretty popular while we
were all working at home
and nala loves her daily dose of
sunshine sitting out on the patio
she just likes to sit out there and soak
up some vitamin d and there she is at
christmas oh
they're so cute all adopted from
different uh shelters and organizations
and john
and of course as we've talked about
before here's my tyrannosaurus rex
mark just a real source of
comfort during this pandemic has helped
make sure that there's no bugs around
the house
and also helps just to quickly toast my
bread
for the bread he can't hold up like this
and it takes care of it this much